welcome to this video playing the fair
town okay we need five here and let's
see what happens very much looking
forward by the way to the new to some
new books on e4 e5 there's a book by
Victor Borge on coming out or maybe it
is already out at the time of this video
could be it's a close ain't supposed to
be wait let's not screw things up here
that night a five immediately and then
c5 I think so hmm easily confuse myself
him that's somewhat rare line tearful
soon thank you five yeah Beauregard's
book this is Bo Logan's andrewy Lopez
and they will feature the marshal attack
and and the brave variation so two lines
and they're in the way very nice
selection I mean Marshall being a
theoretically good state for for ages
now hmm yep should be a choice kind of
both sides i'm going back and the brea
is very solid in the closed story so a
very very sensible selection and i'm
interested in both actually even though
the marshal is some yeah it's a bit of a
tall order to learn especially
considering that you will get anti
marshals very often even though they
might not be that threatening so it's an
interesting thing and the brass is good
anyway so cheeks and i'm taking on
default I guess twice on night before is
probably
run not good yeah I wanted to say I'm
rubbish but that's a bit bit bit would
mean ok so I'm going to do this this
open our Spanish center something that
you get really quite often so I can
regroup maybe the swoopy 8 Bishop evade
not sure I want to go 97 and allow 95
this tablet positions are are usually
somewhere between equal and slightly
better for wide it depends on some
specifics usually White's got to well
probably have to take with the bishop
here mmm probably have to I'm not happy
to do that for sure if aight i guess so
takes TX moon mighty cage 6m we should
have a droopy at create bishop age six
might be on came
hmm maybe anyway can also take within my
Dhoni eight that's a bit passive this
pollution hmm so Queen takes bishop age
6 is that really happening probably yes
okay i might have queen d3m double
attacking age 7 8 p-5 hmm
yeah might be but anyway let's see what
happens queen bee three I can also go
g64 Bishop g7 hmm the ticking the
somewhere looking at the six attacking
us but strong them okay I'm going for
Bishop g7 need to activate a little bit
here Queen might come to perform yeah
why does better here b5 is week six is
somewhat weak ma'am hmm
Jim can't it be 58 queen before this
kind of thing will always be better for
white somewhat and all this immediately
I was thinking 85 is an idea maybe 85
queen bee five would be eight yeah I
think I'm killing for that
Quincy for before would be rather
embarrassing but could he could happen
rook c8 oopsie white resemblance yeah
very very sudden end to the game and
that definitely was to us a little bit
and I somehow screwed up this opening a
bit is it before that you play here I
think this before actually I think I
forgot about that move this is the way
to go idea said this is really very nice
for black I've got 94 coming all night
before and we can go see 5 later yeah I
think this is right ooh sorry I was the
wrong button TM we should be 695 I
didn't like so I got for this d for ya
here why it is definitely a bit better
so no and we should have eight I think
this this must be right and now we can I
know you should improve some are we at
Bishop d3 is given by the computer
looking at the pawn and it's already
very annoying yeah someday learn here
might just might just grab the pawn and
yeah it's more more or less winning yeah
the Greek Queen side here really proved
to be a big problem this this was some
giving me a little bit of um yeah
helping me a little bit and after that I
think I think I should be somewhat okay
even though the engine does not agreed
and we care about this is served
a big mistake but I'm a bit surprised
that the computer gives white a very
clear advantage here I understood the
two bishops of course but now maybe 85
is also quite we again gal to be
difficult to keep their pawn yeah that
was very lucky that he blundered
blundered the piece there I think the
opening result there was just just not
very good I should go with this be four
move instead of c-5 here before us is
better than c5 okay well thanks for
watching